you're a huge Lord of the Rings fan I am
one of the biggest Lord of the Rings
fans yes when you really know your stuff
I do know my stuff you a quiz Miko a
quiz man I don't know enough to quake
you know bro quiz you I used to where is
the stone of gore bar I reside I don't
know man it's not that it's not the
stone of gore but listen it's it's Riven
Dale and they have it look see I'm going
too far I'm showing my nerd I'm sure
minor Smeagol was like one of my first
key impressions that I did yeah I really
nailed I'll just be walking around be
like smooth pipe rustles we won't you
stupid why don't you
[Laughter]
good man so you know it you really know
you got the aurochs you got it all I
mean yours know that whole world
I got a constant I think that the orcs
were the black people in Lord of the
Rings were two orcs because there wasn't
no other one you know I mean you see
nobody else for real like we all lend
the makeup and everything
sorry we still won I'm saying man Lord
orys I should do out like all that
fantasy stuff man like like I do your
Pirates of the Caribbean like all of
that because ultimately I would love
that's where I'm trying to get to I'm
trying to get into that realm you know I
mean I want to get like a Pirates of
Caribbean movie yeah I could be black
Sparrow yeah black Sparrow yes Johnny
Depp looks at me and we're doing this
we're doing a little thing the little
mirror thing that they used to doing
like Looney Tunes yeah yeah you're like
go back and forth and it's like he's
like wow you look you don't look
anything like me and I'm like I know but
you know I sound just like you so just
take that you know in the quest or the
black Sparrow great you're gonna see
this I want you in the next movie hey
man I got a I'm trying to make away they
I've been working on my body to trying
to get that Marvel superhero my I had to
shoot and shoot you know I'm saying I'm
trying to be a superhero I'm tired of
people mistaken me for Anthony Mackie we
are not the same person
we're not you're not the same person not
him not Michael che
not Lamora davis from new girl we are
not the same and if you thought that's
what was congratulations you're racist
that's all I gotta say
not congratulations you're racist who
you know was you don't get to hear that
every day well you know and they should
do this yeah look at people like he went
there yes yes
this is tonin people yeah yeah it is
funny how when you Trump has become like
Voldemort he mentioned his name
you